how could we forget about the highest
grossing zombie film of all time this
juggernaut's Resurrection on Netflix
proves our viewers are still hungry for
zombie action if you find yourself
needing more zombie action once The Last
of Us wraps up its first season There's
Hope for anyone interested in watching a
bunch of zombies pile on top of one
another to climb over a wall and who
isn't Netflix has the answer with 2013's
World War Z I began my investigation on
the assumption
said zombies they meant zombies based on
the 2006 book of the same name by Max
Brooks son of Comedy filmmaker Mel
Brooks the two titles do have some
differences the book features a
collection of different interviews with
survivors of the zombie outbreak it
showcases different perspectives to
provide a more global perspective on
what an undead apocalypse would look and
feel like on the other hand the movie
World War Z is a more straightforward
action horror film where Brad Pitt plays
a former United Nations investigator who
finds himself tasked with bringing about
a solution to the devastation I think
they're spreading a pathogen and they
need a healthy host the movie received
mixed reviews when it initially came out
it didn't tell matters and prior to its
release the film was plagued with
production issues Damon Lindelof was
brought in to clean up the script and
Paramount invested 20 million dollars in
reshoots the finished product may be
divisive but for fans of zombie media
it's essential viewing the zombie
sub-genre isn't going anywhere anytime
soon HBO's The Last of Us proves there's
still a way to tell compelling stories
within the medium and The Walking Dead
is getting a slew of spin-offs zombie
stories are here to stay even with its
deviations from The Source material and
troubled production many critics were
able to look past those issues and take
the film for what it was a high concept
action film with zombies at the center
of the conflict film critic Christy
Lemire compared the movie favorably to
aliens writing as both thrilling
spectacle and Escapist summer
entertainment World War Z is enormously
effective with Brad Pitt at the center
hopscot using the globe in search of the
origin of a zombie apocalypse a good
proportion of the film's praise went
toward director Mark Forrester who has
an Eclectic filmography including
Monster's Ball a man called Otto and
Christopher Robin I always get to where
I'm going by walking away from where I
have been Sean axmaker of stream on
demand wrote Foster proves adeptic
choreographing the chaos of a world
overrun by The Hive behavior of zombie
masses and creating a cinematic order to
the presentation everyone's experience
will differ but clearly World War Z
struck a chord with some making it worth
another look in fact World War Z Remains
the highest grossing zombie movie of all
time with a global take of 540 million
dollars at the box office the budget may
have been close to 190 million dollars
but it's still an impressive return so
it shouldn't come as a surprise to hear
Paramount wanted to turn it into a
franchise be prepared for anything
foreign
[Music]
has just begun World War Z2 wasted away
in development hell for many years now
at one point David Fincher was on board
to direct which would have meant another
team up with Brad Pitt after fruitful
collaborations on seven Fight Club and
The Curious Case of Benjamin Button
unfortunately it wasn't meant to be
Paramount poured the plug on the sequel
in 2019 reportedly due to budget
concerns Fincher and Pitt have moved on
to other projects but it's in this era
of streaming could there be another way
for World War Z to rise from the dead
and gain New Life honestly a World War Z
streaming series wouldn't be a bad idea
even if Pitt turned down the project the
series could be a reboot perhaps more
closely aligning with the original
intention of the novel seeing how the
film is still drawing viewers on Netflix
it's clear that there are people out
there still invested in the property
much like the monsters themselves you
can't get rid of zombies that easily so
don't be surprised if World War Z
Returns the screens in one manner or
another
foreign